[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo a América por ello saludo en
el estudio a nuestra editora económica
Daniel hablando Hola Muy buenos días
Andrés Daniela muy buenos días también
avanza la visita de Janet yelen a China
y con esto iniciamos nuestra Crónica
económica Claro que sí pues es la
noticia económica de la semana está
visita de la secretaría del tesoro de
Estados Unidos que cumple su segundo día
de reuniones en Beijing allí fue
recibida por el propio Primer Ministro
liquidan quien hizo una analogía con el
clima para describir las tensas
relaciones que hay entre las dos mayores
economías del mundo
Ayer cuando usted llegó a nuestro
aeropuerto y se bajó del avión apareció
un arcoiris en el cielo es un fenómeno
natural por supuesto y es algo que vemos
a menudo pero creo que también debería
aplicarse a la relación entre China y
Estados Unidos creo que las relaciones
entre China y Estados Unidos son más que
viento y lluvia seguramente veremos más
arco iris
Esta visita no ocurre en un momento
fácil Andrés recordemos que Beijing hace
apenas unos días impuso restricciones a
las exportaciones de germanio y de galio
Estos son dos metales utilizados en la
industria de la alta tecnología y lo que
se ve como un contragolpe también en una
larga disputa comercial lo que teme el
mercado es que ahora Estados Unidos vaya
a contraatacar como lo está haciendo
china ayer en criticó esta medida y dijo
que quería reparar esos conflictivos
lazos que los unen Daniela y los precios
de los alimentos cayeron a su nivel más
bajo en dos años así lo señala por lo
menos la organización para la
alimentación y la agricultura de
Naciones Unidas que mensualmente les
hace seguimiento a través del índice
compuesto por cinco grupos de los de
alimentos que son los más
comercializados a nivel mundial este
informe de junio lo que muestra es que
hubo una caída en el costo del azúcar
también de los aceites vegetales
los cereales y los productos lácteos
este puntaje de junio también es el más
bajo desde abril de 2021 y significa que
el índice ahora está un 23,4% por debajo
de un máximo histórico que había sido
alcanzado en marzo de 2022 tras el
comienzo de la invasión Rusia
de Ucrania bien y también la misma
organización describe una preocupación
pues tiene que ver Andrés con el
desperdicio mundial de comida por año
que casi llega a las mil millones de
toneladas y representa el 14% de todo lo
que se produce anualmente como lo vemos
en este gráfico la organización prevé
que ese desperdicio se va a incrementar
en la próxima década por los riesgos que
tienen que ver con varios factores por
ejemplo el primero de ellos es el alza
en los precios de la energía esto reduce
la productividad los cultivos se ven
afectados y por eso se desperdicia la
comida también el incremento en el
precio de los fertilizantes recordemos
que por la guerra en Ucrania también se
dio un incremento mundial en el precio
de los fertilizantes porque este país es
uno de los mayores productores
exportadores de insumos agrícolas los
distintos sistemas de producción de
alimentos también se van a enfrentar al
reto de adaptarse lo antes posible a los
efectos del cambio climático como las
cada vez más frecuentes sequías e
inundaciones que están afectando cul
sabemos como en el sur del continente
americano pues todas estas sequías están
afectando gravemente a lo que es
conocido pues como la despensa mundial
de grados y a propósito del fenómeno del
niño que fue declarado oficialmente
durante el inicio de esta semana y de
los todos los días que Estamos rompiendo
récords en temperaturas Así es Daniela
el pulso entre meta y Twitter amenaza
con llegar al plano jurídico Pues
estamos hablando de Fresh que es esta
aplicación con la que el gigante de Mark
& Soccer Beck piensa hacerle competencia
a elon musk o le está haciendo desde ya
competencia con una interfaz que
inclusive es muy parecida a Twitter
lleva apenas dos días en el mercado Ya
tiene más de 30 millones de
suscripciones había logrado en apenas
siete horas más de 10 millones de
suscripciones en la noche del miércoles
salió a criticar a su rival diciendo que
una cosa es competir y otra cosa es
hacer trampa de inmediato también su
abogado a través de una carta le acusó
de contratar a ex empleados que según lo
tenían y continúan teniendo acceso a los
secretos comerciales de Twitter y otra
información también altamente
confidencial entonces informó el medio
semáforo que la empresa del Pájaro Azul
tiene la intención de hacer cumplir
estrictamente su derecho de propiedad
intelectual Así que esto amenaza con
llegar a los tribunales ya y los más no
es nuevo en tribunales recordemos que
cuando hizo la compra de Twitter tuvo
que enfrentarse en tribunales para poder
terminar esta compra porque los
accionistas no estaban de acuerdo y es
una situación que se veía venir porque
por ejemplo hemos visto como los
usuarios en redes sociales han hecho las
comparaciones entre Cómo es la
plataforma de Twitter y cómo es esta
nueva plataforma de Twitch que es
prácticamente igual lo único que le
falta son los mensajes directos y las
tendencias pero claro y yo pienso que
eso llegará con el tiempo pero también
tiene que ver con todo este tema de que
es una es situación que se produce
después de que Twitter hubiera echado a
muchos de sus empleados y muy
seguramente va algunos de estos
empleados ya están en trabajando para
Mark Zuckerberg Así es vamos a ver cómo
avanza entonces este proceso judicial
Daniela vamos a cambiar de tema
nuevamente España le apuesta a las
energías renovables en Ecuador pues está
la empresa villonaco Energy que es
filial del grupo español cobra acaba de
firmar un contrato con el gobierno de
ese país Ecuador para la construcción y
operación por 25 años de un proyecto de
energía eólica está contemplando una
inversión de 181 millones de dólares en
la sureña provincia de Loja allí de
hecho ya funciona una central desde 2013
que fue la primera eólica que se
construyó en Ecuador
cuando entren operación en el 2025 será
el parque de generación eólica más
grande del país
y producirá la energía suficiente como
para abastecer
30.000 hogares es decir a una ciudad de
120.000 habitantes
además su funcionamiento evitará la
emisión de
321,000 toneladas de CO2 a la atmósfera
ingeniera vamos con nuestra célebre
cifra del día pues uno coma siete
dólares es la cifra de hoy Andrés Este
es el precio récord de un kilogramo de
tomate en varias regiones de India ese
valor de venta al por mayor subió 288
por ciento en apenas un mes y ha llevado
a las personas a reducir su consumo pero
usted Se preguntará Por qué le estoy
hablando de tomates indios el día de hoy
en la crónica
Pues porque los dueños de las
franquicias del gigante de las comidas
rápidas McDonald's decidieron eliminar
los tomates de sus hamburguesas y raps
en muchos puntos de venta en este país
el más poblado del mundo incluidos
algunos en la capital Nueva Delhi están
afectados Andrés por la escasez de
suministros y también por el consecuente
aumento en el precio de esta verdura el
gobierno dice que los precios más altos
del tomate se deben a una temporada de
producciones casa porque las lluvias
monzónicas interrumpen tanto el
transporte como la distribución Yo sé
que esta noticia a usted no le afecta
porque usted siempre a la a la
hamburguesa le quita el tomate y me lo
da a mí eso iba a decir a usted debe
estar afectándole estas noticias
esperemos que no se ve la situación en
Colombia usted
téngalo por seguro Daniela Muchas
gracias por la información económica nos
vemos entonces en un momento con la
actualización y Les traigo los
indicadores de la jornada